maest
Moss
the might
might
be
my 20 years the Empire had ruled us but
no
longer Liberty or
[Music]
death Liberty or
[Applause]
death
[Music]
rga's Beacon nears its
end soon my friends aliko will be ours
once
more
H so spirited and so
[Music]
empty then what was it all for what will
you say to the families of the Fallen to
the the mothers and the widows and the
orphans will you tell them it was all
for
nothing hold the line by
rer traitor kid
Slayer though our battlefields be a
th000 mes apart our purpose is
one it is better to bend With the Wind
than stand tall and be broken
therein lies hope therein lies freedom
ohami of the fathomless Waters of the
Fallen the ascended the flowing and the
bealed cleanse these ones of Earth and
stone and Grant them your blessing that
they might drink deep of the
[Applause]
[Music]
Divine
so my blade or my head which would you
have of
[Applause]
me
[Music]
Pro
the
looky where the sun doth rise see
Crimson Embers darkening
Skies looky where the sun doth fall see
Azure lost amidst the
[Applause]
Sall only man has the wisdom and the
clarity to Embrace violence for its own
sake